Rắn nếu bày tháng sáng lực lận về bánh tính mạng của giáo Irban Irrogoses toy bố,
đã thực hiện của tập kích bằng tên lua nhằm bà chụ sử tình báo quân độ Isoran,
và chúng tâm lên kế hoài của mô sá cải thay naveb.
Irrogoses sẽ cũng cho biết,
khá địa điểm này đã bóc trai bất chấp để thống phòng công việc đại của Isoran.
Hắn thống tâm thật liêm giận lời bố cũng phòng Irban cho biết,
của tập kích sử dụng loại tên lượng mối chứ tình được công bố,
và khẳng định phòng không Isoran không thể đánh trạng.
Chúng khi đó, chuyển thống Isoran đang cải hình ngành các vụ trái lớn,
và của khỏi bất cao cải tháng phố Hé Vía,
nơi đặt tổng hành dinh của mô sát.
Môn tín tả Irban cho sang,
in nhất bốn tên lời đã giấu xong của vận gли lắm,
được cho là chung tâm hộ cân của tình báo của Noisoran.
Lực lộng phòng về Isoran y đẹp sắc nhận,
khoảng 2 mối tên lộ đàn đạo được Irban phòng đi,
khiến nhất năm 2019 và gây tại bất chất tải mùa bại đựng xe.
Công thẳng léo thang từ ngày 18 tháng sau,
khi Isoran mở chính xe không kích có tên xương tự trối dạy.
Nhằm vân yêu mục tiêu cấp cao cải Irban, Irban sau đó,
đã chả bằng chính xe lời nữa để thử bà.
Cô đối Isoran tuyên bố đã phá hủy mùa vận bà,
số bệnh phóng tiên lời của Irban,
sông dời chuyên xa cạnh báo,
các đận tập kinh bắn tiêm ăn như dù dù, đối vẻ anh ninh khu vực.